man
is a rope stretched between the animal
and the ubermensch a rope over an abyss
a dangerous crossing a dangerous on the
way
a dangerous looking back a dangerous
trembling and standing still
what is great in man is that he is a
bridge
and not a purpose that which is lovable
in man is that
he is a transition and a downfall
i love those who don't know how to live
except when they perish
for they are those who cross over to the
other side
i love the great despisers for they are
the great worshipers
and arrows of yearning for the other
side
i love those who don't first look behind
the stars for a reason to perish
and to be a victim but those who
sacrifice themselves to the earth
so that the earth may one day belong to
the ubermensch
i love him who lives to gain knowledge
and wishes to gain knowledge
so that the ubermensch can live one day
and so he wishes his downfall i love him
who works
and invents so that he can build the
ubermensch's house
and prepare earth animals and plants for
him
for this is how he wants his downfall i
love him who loves his virtue
for virtue is the will to downfall and
an arrow of yearning
i love him who doesn't keep a single
drop of spirit for himself
but wishes to be entirely the spirit of
his virtue
so he strides as a spirit across the
bridge
i love him who turns his virtue into his
addiction
and his undoing thus he wants for his
virtues sake
both to live and to live no more i love
him who doesn't want to have too many
virtues
one virtue is more virtue than two
because
it is more of a knot upon which one's
undoing
can hang from i love him whose soul is
wasted
who asks for no thanks and gives nothing
back
for he always gives and doesn't want to
preserve himself
i love him who is ashamed when the dice
fall in his favor
and who then asks have i been cheating
for he wield his own perishing i love
him who voices golden words
before his actions and still keeps even
more than he promises
for he wants his downfall i love him who
justifies those in the future
and redeems those in the past for he
wishes to be destroyed
by those in the present i love him who
chastises his god
because he loves his god for he must be
destroyed
by the wrath of his god i love him whose
soul
is deep even when wounded and who can
perish from a minor experience
thus he's glad to cross the bridge i
love him whose soul
is so full that he forgets himself and
all things are in him
so all things will be his downfall
i love him who is free in spirit and
heart so his head is only the gods of
his heart
but his heart pushes him to his downfall
i love all those who are like heavy
drops
falling one by one from the dark cloud
that hangs over mankind they herald the
coming of the lightning
and thus heralds they also perish behold
i am a hurled of the lightning and a
heavy drop from the cloud
but this lightning is called ubermensch
hey
you